this is the most anticipated comedy of
the year is there pressure when you know
that and you know that so many people
are waiting on this we have the bar that
we try to hit that luckily people have
you know uh seem to enjoy so why did it
take over a year for us to get a new
season I think everyone involved is a
sort of obsessive perfectionist wake up
at three in the morning like hey what if
you know we need to fix this hey coach I
don't know about you but kind of feels
like it's getting a little stuffy in
here yeah what to watch for season
s are you having
paneling your inner bad guy oh yeah that
is fun but it is it is a world away from
the more bumbling sort of awkward
socially awkward kit man that we were
introduced to in season one and uh you
know occasionally I do miss that side of
Nate two Roy Kent right jump oh Roxanne
just said great job Roy Kent has so many
famous lines do you have fans constantly
like yelling at you do they say
I did have one weird interaction where I
was walking down the street and a man I
think he was nervous and he sort of
walked towards me anyway and then walk
straight past me and I thought what's
going on another oh yeah I'm rocking and
three romance we see Roy and Keely kind
of on a path of trouble do you think
that they are in game I certainly do
okay I mean if you're asking me as a fan
yes I I and just to check end game means
it means it means like we're together
forever we're happily ever after
and one of us has to die tragically to
save the other
you know I am team Rebecca and Sam I
will be till the day I die do you think
he and Rebecca will wind up together
whenever they're in a crowded room and
like they lock eyes for a second there's
always going to be a bit of like spark
or potential there I'm rooting for them
both to be happy
do you believe that the fans will be
satisfied How It Ends we went into it
thinking this would be the last you know
now we're not as sure but this will be
the end of the story that we set out to
tell if you're not satisfied where do
you go like where do you protest need to
revoke and then we'll see what happens
thank you
foreign